one more item of news on this wednesday
morning edition of pft live chris you've
said in the past that john gruden views
his offense as a ferrari and he entrusts
the quarterback with the keys to it
john gruden had two choices on monday
night buy a ferrari at least a used
ferrari or set aside a hundred thousand
dollars to pay to the nfl by not wearing
a mask during the game against the
saints well john you could have had a
real ferrari because now a hundred
thousand dollars is disappearing both he
and sean payton the saints head coach
find that amount the same amount that
was uh
taken from kyle shanahan vic fangio and
pete carroll based upon what happened
sunday when they blatantly refused to
wear their masks we've got five coaches
now with fines of a hundred thousand
dollars their teams find 250 000 each i
poked around yesterday chris to see if
there was any momentum toward
getting rid of the requirement that
coaches wear masks because look you know
we went back to kind of the original
stance here they were going to test
everyone three times a week you got to
wear the masks on the sideline when it
morphs into we're going to test everyone
every day and they haven't announced it
yet but they're going to do it all
season long you don't need the coaches
to wear masks but
but no one is going to retreat from that
position unless they have to and unless
the owners take over and say we don't
want this and more than 24 of us are
going to vote in favor of getting rid of
that rule the rule is staying there so
john gruden knows sean payton knows pete
carroll came out and said hey sometimes
you got to get coached up and you get
coached up to the tune of having six
figures taken out of your bank account
but uh you know the good news is this
fine money goes to charity but other
than that hey where are the masks mike
tomlin came out yesterday and said it's
not that hard go ahead and wear it you
and i have conversed about whether it
does impede the ability to call plays
but
other guys are doing it and calling
plays even if mike tomlin doesn't call
plays right others are doing it and
calling plays so the expectation is that
all will yeah you're right that's that's
the you know you're right there's plenty
that are following the rules and doing
it the right way calling the plays with
the mask on uh i i just you know again i
don't love the rule for the reasons you
explained i don't and you know at the
very least i mean okay john gruden takes
his mass down and now he's on the
sideline yelling green ride x shift of
viper ride 382 x stick lucky with all
these people around him the mask is down
he's it's at the the optimal point for
him to spray
uh you know mouth fluid everywhere all
right and do that
but hey that's all right now put the
mask back on while you don't talk and uh
watch the play i mean it just it's
optics at that point it's optics that's
that's the only thing i'm arguing here
and like you said it's an everyday
testing if there is a group or a group
of people that should be able to go
without a mask in the world right now at
the workplace it would be an nfl coach
or an nfl player there is nobody under
more strict uh what do i want to say you
know circumstances or anything like that
in all the world there's nobody being
monitored more closely that's what i
wanted to say damn work every damn day
and you've got the players walking
around the facility with the devices
that beep if they get within six feet of
each other right now it all goes out the
window when it's time to play a game and
the whole idea is let's keep everyone
safe so we can play a game and not have
to worry about it but that's the point
and that's where we go coaches are part
of this effort to keep everyone safe so
we can play a game and not worry about
it we don't need to have this optical
illusion of people wearing masks and
folks look here's the thing if the nfl
is concerned about the optics i mean
first of all the optics are confusing
because the players don't have masks on
and second of all
look around the the optics battle
has been lost yes it has either you are
sufficiently conscientious to wear a
face covering or you're not it's like
any other political issue right now and
this shouldn't be a political issue no
one's mind is going to be changed you've
either resolved you're going to do it or
you've resolved that you're not and
there's no middle ground
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports